de base est que la situation est
déséquilibré notamment au cours des 20 à
30 dernières années
d'intelligence élevé a toujours été très
estimé par la société humaine et cela
devrait l'être je ne veux pas donner
l'impression que je suis anti
intelligence nous avons besoin de
personnes intelligentes pour inventer
par exemple des vaccins contre la polio
19 pour réussir à réduire le taux de co2
dans notre atmosphère nous en avons eu
en plus que j'allais mais au cours des
récentes décennies
il y avait trop de prestige trop de
récompenses pour les travailleurs de la
tête est le symbole de cela c'est
l'expansion énorme de des études
supérieures dans nos sociétés modernes
la pandémie a effectivement braqué à un
projecteur très intéressant sur ses
différences les personnes qui ne sont
pas allés à l'université ont été elles
et travailleurs de première ligne est
vraiment vitaux dans cette crise les
gens qui gardait les supermarchés
ouverts les livreurs les champs et les
gens qui se débarrasser d'une autre
belle et il est venu il est devenu
extrêmement fabre ans que nous dépendons
de ces gens bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
personnes intelligentes travaillant par
exemple dans les hôpitaux les docteurs
les infirmiers mais aux travailleurs de
la non play tous ceux qui ne sont pas en
premier les travailleurs de la tête
était vraiment au coeur de la crise et
cela permet de son acer équilibré dans
la distribution du statut de l'année du
prestige au sein de notre société
[Musique]